their bus fee this is how I look with
makeup and this is how I look without
makeup my name is Shalon I grew up in
Nigeria where my family owns a fast food
store when I was nine years old my
sister and I fell asleep under the table
where my mother fries food we sold we
will fast asleep when a hot oil above a
certain leaf fell pouring all over my
face and body I remember screaming and
crying as my family pour water on us and
my burning flesh falling on the ground I
spent four months in the hospital my
eyes couldn't open and my fingers
couldn't straighten when I returned to
school I quickly realized life after the
incident wasn't what I thought it would
be
kids will bully and stare at me
sometimes they even ran away because my
face scared them they call me burn face
to face Scarface I'm so on I felt like a
living statue for people to come see
then I discovered makeup tutorials on
YouTube I watched I was the point hours
of videos to learn how to do makeup and
to know it was good
my question is that it asked me to do
they make up fold them but I still
didn't feel happy
soon I study having suicide thoughts
eventually I came across to lead your
leader girl hair on you to fighting
cancer and like me she didn't have any
hair I was amazed by her courage to come
on camera without a wig on June 17 2014
I posted a photo of myself without a wig
on Instagram for the first time to my
surprise people were positive and
encouraging and said my father
inspire them to also be bold I felt like
a load was taken off of my shoulders
because I was finally being honest I'm
not giving a crap what anyone has to say
about my parents this led me wanting to
share more with people because if Thalia
could do it so could i and if I can
anyone can so I decided to start my own
Beauty China
wanted to help other people like me not
only to learn how to do makeup but to
learn to love themselves for who they
truly are makeup is not the reason why
I'm happy it is something I enjoy doing
I'm happy because I've learned to love
myself I'm happy that I can be myself
and share my passion with the world as
you can see this is how I look with
makeup and with that makeup and I lost
both of the slide equally
[Music]